i'd had about a year of just
being mentally rock bottom i'd been
drinking
and i didn't care about myself at all
i had the worst depression people i
loved it died i'd gone from 19 stone to
25 stone i mean we had a conversation
last week and he said to me if i don't
do it now i'll never do it
i'm not saying i'm gonna sort it i'm
saying i'm gonna start
[Music]
trying
just standing there [__] getting
[__] up
here we go again it's the rebuild
episode two
you might remember the last rebuild
where i decided to film a month of
training enough to let myself get really
out of shape be really down and
depressed and low
and i was like i need something to just
turn this [__] thing around
and this fat boy weightlifter who talks
about football and fighting
was going to try and lace the gloves up
and actually learn how to box
and show you all of the worst of me in
that first month
including at the end of the first month
we get in the ring
we do five rounds of pads with my boxing
coach who just so happens to be an 18
stone bad [__] who's had 40
fights in his life
and then we put the gloves on together
and we do body sparring and
he just showed me what it was really
about now body sparring isn't even
anywhere near as bad as full sparring
but it's still
for a guy who was die out of shape who'd
never boxed before i was in shock like
what the [__] is going on right now i'm
trying to keep this guy off me
and he is all over me and i got a
newfound respect
for pro boxers weirdly i loved it
so we carried on as best we could
because there was four months
roughly between then and now and half of
that was locked down so
you're gonna see months two and three of
me learning how to box in this
and i want to give a big shout out to
jim shock before we get into this
gymshark 66 is a campaign where they're
encouraging people
like you and me to take up a new habit
and to better themselves and
usually takes 66 days in order to make
that habit part of you
part of your norm and that's what this
is all about so i'm going to put the
link in the description
below they're a great bunch of lads
they're always checking in on me and
encouraging me
and we want you to be a part of that so
check the link out
and let's pick up where we left off at
the end of month one
i was happy with last week even though i
got so good
people you don't get it brian don't
mean without talking about it you don't
bri don't get it you know how many
people
quit would quit when i watched it
you under pressure oh yeah you know how
many people to quit
and then i suppose i don't really know
that yeah you know
the objective is to make you feel that
that pressure oh yeah
but this is the box the caveat
you have to i want you to learn how to
feel like that
and still execute what you've been
taught and
to be in pain to feel the pain and
execute what you've been doing
yeah that's the key that's it
that's a good job you've got there jeff
that's it
try and extend your hip a little bit
that's it i'm normally used to going
this way
you're a power man yeah but that's not
the key yeah
that's not how you get the power you're
tightening up you get you get the power
right
through speed and being loose
right into the body straight oh sorry
sorry this guy pain threshold it's not
normal
you can give a little cheeky nudge okay
there you go added layer of defense
there you go
i like it see your fast learner
now your head's not coming up remember
it's about asking questions so
if i throw that combination and i
realize
you can't you don't bend your knees now
you're in trouble so i'm gonna keep
doing it more
okay okay bang
bang look what you're gonna get
it's worth it i'm telling ya
now you're learning
spin out beautiful but
can you do it in real life when you're
under pressure
you've got me hunting you down
free free
well done more or less you're not going
to learn it all
overnight because it takes years to
learn yeah
it takes years to learn oh yeah i like
that life because there's things i've
learned that i've learned the hard work
ended up on my back in front of people
you're called better
green embarrassing not getting your head
punched here
how many uh do you think i had four
five four four fives well not every
success but most success successes
begin with failures yeah true
so you could say i failed but everything
i learned
i passed on to my son so we avoid the
potholes yeah
he avoids the potholes so i say don't do
that don't do that this is the way
forward
does um does that feeling of the failure
still stick with you now no i don't
i don't feel like oh i'm a failure like
that because i understand
it on a deeper level now i understand
i'm wise
i'm always learning so i understand on a
deeper level that wasn't my calling
yeah this being a a
a professional or a world champion
british that was that's not that wasn't
my calling
that's my son's call yeah and i'm
i've been put on this earth to help him
get there
in those sessions in the studio where
some people who don't know boxing might
look they didn't think this is two
blocks dashing around with some gloves
on
i am learning so much i'm getting the
[__] education from derrick he
knows so much about boxing this guy's
spent his whole life
devoted to boxing when you go around to
his flat boxing
channel is on and he's watching it
there's po posters and pictures around
of
ricky hat and manny pacquiao fight not
you know his son
is a great up and coming boxer he lives
and breathes it so
when i'm getting that information he is
checking
all the time are you absorbing this you
know if this happens what do you do
if that happens how do you react i've
taught you this and like if you fail
a question at school you get a little
cross next to it it's not a big deal
derek will be like you're gonna get hit
and i'm gonna show you how painful
that's gonna feel
he gives you no choice but to get better
not just that he makes me a better
person
you know when you're around someone
who's had all that life experience um
he encourages me all the time he keeps
it real like he credits me
or he picks me up on things i need to do
better you can only become a better
bloke when you're around
a man who is as hard as derek but as
good-hearted as derek
one two one two one one one
what
hitting the heavy bag is the worst i
don't like it
like you know doing pads a little bit
flashy in the ring it's more exciting
the heavy bag just
is quite soul destroying at times
because i find it a bit boring
and also with every time i hit that bag
those
muscles in my arms and my shoulders are
just getting slower
and more full of blood and more fatigue
because they're made for weightlifting
this is still new
and it's so tiring
right here ryan
ryan
dab in right uppercut right let's go
yeah move up
walk hey block him beast
block
and as you can see those big muscles in
mind are pretty [__] useless
as the fatigue sets in and as the pad
work is
draining me because you can have as big
a muscles as you want if your shoulders
are not conditioned to throw
constant punches you're going to blow
that load very [__] quickly
and at this point i'm not conditioned
for it that's why derek is drilling that
and making me keep throwing don't quit
keep going keep going pads aren't a
fight a lot of people can look great on
pads and do
football in a real fight but you can get
an idea of someone's output
by watching pads and right now you can
see my output is
you know i look [__] thunderous for
about a minute and then it's all
downhill from there
the heavy bag is surprisingly draining
you know and
yeah you know you know what hold that
phone you're gonna be saying that to me
a lot in the next
nine months however long it's going to
be that was surprising to say that
surprised me
that was draining that's harder than it
looks you're gonna be saying that a lot
yeah my goal of this body sparring is to
just not get bullied the way i did last
time
it was rough i just wanna answer him if
he hits me
i'm gonna try and hit him back
yes
[Music]
okay
two two
oh
uh
fine move up
i really for my own self-esteem just
wanted to throw as many punches as i
could just to prove that i
yeah i'm not just going to be walked all
over here and i've got some fightness
you know as much as it was body sparring
and not full sparring like you know i
i felt proud of myself after that one i
might look like a big strong
[__] man but people need to
understand like i'm basically a [__]
kid
when i'm doing this you know what i mean
so that was a big confidence booster
that day i felt great afterwards
you got it now you've got it you've got
it
you let it flow you let it flow now jab
jab
there you go i'm happy but
i feel a sense of pride i appreciate
something man
i appreciate it like my own son huh
appreciate it you know what i mean
hands up ready there you go
you see that there you go
see you got it now there was something
derek said
in that session that sort of caught me
by surprise
he said he felt the sense of pride when
i got something right like i was his own
son
i grew up not really having a lot of
time with my dad
so even now when an older man like him
is putting this time into me and
and trying to improve me and better me
as a person
and then they say something like that it
still makes me feel like a young lad
you know what i mean it meant a lot it's
funny how even now i'm a grown man that
sort of thing can still make me feel
like a young kid
and i actually know derek's son vidal
riley he was my friend who he was the
one who put were together some of you
might know him as ksi's coach
others may know him as the future of
boxing he's got eight national titles
signed to floyd mayweather gone
undefeated as a pro
when i first met vidal i was like how's
this young guy got such a good head on
his shoulder so level-headed
yet got the world at his feet i don't
get it now getting to know derek i get
it
this man will keep anyone grounded but
also
he is the reason vidal is the way he is
kind of like
obviously vidal put the work in and he's
naturally very talented but you i can
tell
like vidal would have been trained
pretty much from the day he could walk
that passion that knowledge that
experience that derek had
and also with the fact that it didn't
work out for him he
probably gave everything he possibly
could to vidal
to turn him into the most unbeatable
machine
possible it's not just about vidal
getting the success that it didn't
happen for
derrick it's derek just loves that kid
like when
he talks about him his face changes i've
seen a lot of
people talk about their kids i've never
known anyone talk about their kid as
much as directors
he absolutely adores him this is the
first time since i've been boxing my
dad's been in my corner
so i want to show my appreciation to him
not just for vidal
as my friend but also to watch derek's
happiness i hope to god
that vidal wins a world title one day
i'm pretty sure it will happen
but you know the good people and he
deserves it
listen he's a man now but like my mind's
stuck my mind's still stuck in the past
isn't it
my mind's my mind stuck in the past from
the days when i used to have hair
like yeah so my mind's stuck there you
know it's like spartans isn't it
you know sparks you've got to go out
they grow up the boys and they gotta go
out and fight the wolf or whatever
they're doing
in their right passage and then come
back and that's what he's doing now
he's a man now so he's got to do his
thing
and there was actually a time where
vidal was training for his fight in
america
and we were in the boxing gym in london
and derek
got one hell of a surprise that's the
art of the game
don't just box one way you know what i
mean
you can't just box one way
that's it you know what i mean
what are you doing there man i'm
surprised dude
just missing beating us up
man oh man
oh man that's good stuff
getting serious man it's getting there
like
yeah split
pivot round that's it
uh
i'm actually starting to think now this
is where all the knowledge that derek
has been putting into me for all those
weeks
is actually starting to be used in a
combat situation so when he's thrown
with the right hand i'm thinking
okay he's open now strike
so you had to be careful there at the
end and not keep punching and then have
nothing left in the tank
but that was without doubt the most
aggressive i'd ever been in the boxing
ring at that point
i can't tell you how demoralizing it is
when you've given your best
and you're getting tired and then
derek's opposite you in the corner just
on his tippy toes just bouncing around
like nothing's happened
oh
hey
that's when you know i'm getting
confident when i'm starting to try and
trick people at something anything
that means i'm relaxed i'm comfortable
i'm thinking
[Music]
i was thinking as much as i could you
know you don't bet when you've got me on
the ropes you're thinking about what
you're doing there you know
yeah i thought i got got to place my
shots here
and you were throwing back as well so it
was giving me even more to think about
that's right because you threw some
cracking shots back so i was like oh
think i remember at the end of that
session just feeling like
huge progress had been made from that
first body sparring session
to then a short space of time but i'd
learned a lot and i was clearly much
better i mean
i was fitter i was able to go longer
without getting tired
i was i was being the aggressor at times
i was thinking
while i was in the ring everything was
coming together
there was one problem i hadn't been
punched in the face yet
and one thing i have that you can't
teach some people add it some people
don't
tell just punch hard
today you'll learn a little bit of that
today left hand only
but you're allowed body shots with both
hands
god
foreign
so
[Music]
wow
one more round
think now brian think about what you're
doing
punch back the drills from the pads
this is where it counts
step out
how'd you find it
get up head up
piss off with myself why because i know
you've probably a lot better than that
it's just difficult uh
i think when you're having to do it all
in the one goal you know
that's the whole point of the exercise
not expecting to be frustrated yeah
it means you can i want to i'd rather go
again
you want to go again i'll rather do
another round or two and actually
no pad see better all right um uh
would you have a two-round dinette and
then maybe do around on the back
even if you kick me off i'd rather try
until i can't
because mentally when i kept getting
tagged
i was uh
i gave up on myself and and i just sort
of took it
rather than thinking even if i do one
more round and happens again at least
i've given it
everything i've got
come on
good job brian good man
yeah he's [__] helped get yourself
together
i'm trying to try it again good man
it's hard man i'm proud of you if that's
hard
you crossed
i miss me mom
yeah be proud of you though
well i miss her so much i don't know
what the [__] this has got to do with
her but
tonight bring that emotions raw
it's visceral it's been on my head a lot
lately
it's good though because this is that
oh god help you to
connect with your deeper emotions
because she's the reason i don't quit
that's right
think about this how many people would
do what you're doing now
should you understand yourself
[Music]
you're
i just don't want to quit you didn't
quite
relaxing yeah sorry lutz come don't
worry about that
listen seeing it all i've seen it all
right
good man
[Music]
let's just choose the person on after
dick deep
[Music]
oh good man
when you were watching that you probably
thought i was all [__] up before
getting hit
um but the whole time i was thinking
about my mom
she's the person who always pushed me on
through every
hard moment every hard time of my entire
life
i never thought i'd speak about this i
might never speak about it again
it's difficult a few years ago my mom
passed away
and i just didn't want to share that
with youtube because it's not a nice
place
to i haven't found it very empathetic
the trolls and that they i didn't want
to give that
special piece of me over for people to
use it against me and hurt my feelings
all the more
but when this happened and we captured
it just randomly on camera in the middle
of some boxing gym
i also thought about a lot of you lot
who were probably feeling the same way
and also that i just didn't want to go
to my grave
without having the chance to tell
everyone how much she means to me
i should not do that just because
there's horrible people out there
so sometimes in life
there are people who devote their entire
lives to
helping others not for money not for
fame not for anything no personal gain
just because they love to help people
and
normally those are the unsung heroes who
never get the credit they deserve
but i have the honor of telling all of
you lot
that my mom was one of those people
an angel that i was
fortunate to not just know
but to have as my mother when i was born
i won the lottery
i could not have met a more caring
kind-hearted
devoted mother she was just
the most beautiful soul
i've ever met in my entire life
everything good about me
everything you like about me it's
because of her and it's always been
because of her when i make you laugh
because i made her laugh and she used to
encourage me to make her laugh
when people sent us messages about
how caring i was when sean atwood was
crying on our podcast and how i said all
the right things
that was because of her
when i make you feel anything
it's because she always encouraged me
to be who i am and not be ashamed of
that
and to believe in myself
always even down to me being a newcastle
fan
like she she queued up for hours to get
me tickets to my first game
and when all the other boys were getting
taken by their dads
there was me with my mom and she was
cheering newcastle on even though she
didn't know a single player
and she would just do anything for us
she was so devoted as a mother
so you like me because of her
everything good about me is because of
her i remember those times where
we didn't have much at christmas and
i remember just hugging her on me bed
and saying it didn't matter because we
had each other
i've never felt love like that
true true love
real real the most powerful love
possible
that's the kind of love that even when
the person leaves you oh
that stays with you and keeps you going
through all the hard times
through all the [__] i've been through
she's the reason that i always keep
going
no matter how hard it gets when i was in
that rain
i just just wanted to not give up
and every tear that i cry
it's because of the warmth that she put
in me
and the man that she made me
i know that some people think i'm this
[__] brick who's up his own ass
big youtuber podcaster true geordi
all i am is a kid who misses his man
deep deep down inside that is who i am
i love her and i miss her every day
she was my mom she was my dad she was my
best friend
we told each other everything
i could trust her with anything
didn't matter
when someone has your back that much it
it's a superpower you know you can
always go with that person
she was the love of my life
and anyone i love after her is just
getting
some of what she gave to me because
without her i would never have been
the person i am
and i know i'm a very flawed person but
anything good in me is from her
i might never talk about this again and
i hope you understand that
but i want you to know
if you like me it's because
and a dedicated everything i
ever achieve
if that is any good to my mom
all the credit to the kid who came
from nothing and made him put herself
into something
because she told me to always believe
i love you mom
[Laughter]
[Music]
when you've never been hit before and
you watch boxers do it on tv
and you see them punching back and forth
and it they act like it's nothing it's
not a big deal
you see them they don't flinch they
don't back off they don't act like
they're hurt
it looks like it's easy they've just
done it for thousands of hours
so it's nothing to them to people like
me and you
oh it's a big deal it's a big
[__] deal when you've never had
someone hit you hard
in the face before and then a man like
derek
who weighs the same as anthony joshua
and has had 40 fights and knows exactly
how to plant a job right in your [__]
grill
you have this moment of boom and it's
all kinds of confusion pain
your body naturally goes oh [__] i don't
want i don't want that happening again
you want to run away you want to get out
of there you don't want to carry on but
you have to
if you want to learn how to parks so i
knew i needed to overcome that before i
could even think about becoming a good
boxer if i can't take a [__] punch i
got no chance
see this year is not me boxing it's me
trying to land one shot and then
covering up for dear life
and it's just a fear of getting hit
[Music]
you've got to do it brian you've just
got to get out there and make sure you
can get [__] punched
but land one
because he's trying to provoke this but
if it's just [__] my confidence of me
for more to be honest because i'm like
he doesn't even need his hands up here i
think i try for something
i finally get the confidence to come in
he easily evades
my job and i left myself wide open for a
good dig
right in the [__] face i'm not just
saying this i really was questioning
what the [__] i was doing at this point
like i'm like i put all this pressure on
myself
to learn how to box everyone knows i'm
trying to learn this
and here i am in the ring thinking you
just can't [__] get over this
getting hit in the face [__] stop being
a [__] [__] and this is very early
on still but i'm just thinking if you
can't do
that then you're never gonna learn so i
tried to
to go out for the next round with that
attitude of this is now or never really
definitely landed with half one derrick
is not trying 100 anywhere near 100
percent here he is lowering his level
to bait me at actually trying to box him
and catch him with that
that punch was a solid job and it gave
me some confidence like yes
i'm in range i'm finally connecting and
i'm not bottling it anymore
now we're back now
when derek said that i got such a
confidence boost because i felt like i'm
competing
a little bit here i'm actually putting
myself in there and i'm going for it a
bit
that's it so it's not working when it's
around
five and derrick says it's time to get
to work now you're like where the [__]
are you being paul
[Music]
one more one more
one [__] more jesus christ the state
of his mind
this is the last one work
come on come on
when you're hitting another man and he's
shouting come on to you it does
something
on the one hand it's [__] motivating
on the other hand you're like
i'm [__] trying bro what the [__] oh
deliberately
there you go there you go there you go
there you go don't get groody
don't get [__] greedy
[Music]
hold on
have you ever seen anything more
pathetic in your life these sessions are
not about me
being a great boxer clearly it's about
me
paying my dues and actually taking
punishment and learning the skills
that's what this is all about and paddy
was saying the same thing he was like
[__] head guards are annoying
i'm like i'm glad you think that yeah
i'm going to try and relax a bit more
dude
if i get hit
[Music]
so what's happening here is we're
supposed to be jabbing now
in my inexperience rather than doing a
straight arm
i've come a little bit around the
outside to catch derrick because his
guards up
that is technically a hook so i done
[__] up
because this is jobs only body shots
derek doesn't
didn't like it very much sorry
you want a hook
just hold it if
that was a straight right to the head
we're not really
supposed to do that by the rules of
derek but
he was teaching me a lesson there like
if you [__] around and then you make
mistakes like that
i'm gonna punish you for it that's what
it's like in a boxing gym sometimes you
know what i mean
[Music]
getting a bit tasty now isn't it
credit to derek right i'm a big guy i
punched him pretty hard in the belly
there and i heard the wind go out of him
but he
he doesn't show anything the guy has a
stone
face like that you never can tell
it was a good job i felt so delighted
like i'm actually [__] landing on him
now like properly he didn't just let me
have that i had to get that i knew the
difference
[Music]
that moment where i slipped the jab it
stuck out in my head because it's one
thing throwing big bombs and hitting the
pads and all of that
but in order to read a punch coming at
you
and to move out the way especially for a
21 stone man i was like wow
i'm really learning the skills here i'm
actually using what he's taught me here
and
for me boxing is the art of hitting
without getting hit and that
showed me i can kind of do this a little
bit right now like a tiny little bit and
that gave me
so much belief and it's so weird when
you
feel the glove slip past your and you're
like oh
what the [__] the problem is i didn't
have the boxing
iq to make him pay for that at the
moment but it was coming there was
something there i was like okay i've
slipped the punch
brilliant
[Music]
derek was not in a good mood that day
you've got no business being a boxing
ring if you don't expect to get hit yeah
you know yeah that's one thing i'm not
going to get hit
you learning it's coming slowly yeah
you're not scared to get it don't get a
bit shaken i'll see it when i hit
when i clip you oh there was like three
well i'm like oh that's a good shot
yeah yeah you're thinking because we
have a good left hook right in the
inside of plex it's a good shot so after
a few spots
where we're using jabs in both hands for
body shots i was finally getting used to
getting hit in the head
so now it was about trying to think more
trying to do
a little bit of more footwork and
actually use some head movement and land
and actually be a better boxer
the levels gone up that's great
it was good to land one shot uh i'm
getting my ass kicked yeah in case you
didn't know
and it's because derek has put the level
up on me he can tell i'm getting used to
getting here
so he's increasing the pressure the
problem is he is so fit
and i am not as fit as him nowhere near
and my gas tank is going
and i'm struggling to survive in there
i am so [__] at this point
sorry what that was the moment where i
realized just how
important my fitness was like derek
hadn't really pushed a pace like that on
me before that was the moment i realized
okay if i'm ever going to be
good at this and able to do the things i
know how to do but can't do
as efficiently because i'm too big and
slow right now
i need to stop running i think you start
[__] doing cardio it actually made me
think about tyson fury [__] me he was
nearly 30 stone and he came back and
the fact that he was able to even box
again let alone win
the heavyweight title it blows my mind
i'm sitting here at 21 stone just like
thinking
i wish i could shed another two stone
but like things like running is really
difficult in my way
so that was the moment where i thought i
need to [__] sort this like because
i want to be able to do this and i want
to be able to be in that ring and not
feel like the main worry is am i going
to get tired at that moment i knew
that if this was a boxing match that i
would have been stopped and
he would have been the winner i would
have been the loser he would have had
the glory i would have had my ass kicked
all of that and i sort of got a chance
to sort of think oh
what does that actually feel like you
know because i've watched so many
fights before obviously there's nothing
on the line i'm not dealing with the
consequences of a pro fighter
but i was okay with it i was like okay
like you know no shame in it really i
mean
derek's had 40 [__] fights for
chrysler he's a hard man and i didn't
feel any
hurt male pride or shame or try my best
i'm learning it's gonna happen
it's fine the punch itself sucked but it
was more that i just
left myself vulnerable by not doing
enough cardio so that i was in a place
where
i couldn't defend myself properly i was
pissed off at myself
okay you're looking down the side of
this rifle you want to keep your sight
locked in
to your opponent my rifle sight is going
where you're going so that's how
you must be once i jab that once twice
you gotta get over there you gotta move
[Music]
this is the line yeah
move that's it up away that's it
other way other way that's the line
let me have it all my way look all day
long
look walk to the right when i want to
look
no hands up concentrate that lead leg
in line with mine when i move it you
move yours
move it let's say you cut someone off
this session was a bit of a
psychological breakthrough because even
though i was kind of getting used to
getting hit now
i was still doing some of those bad
habits that you do when you're avoiding
the exchanges because you're a bit
defensive you're backing off you're
you're circling the wrong way i wasn't
acting like the big man which i am the
big man so i should be
imposing my size on anyone who's in
there with me but i wasn't i was acting
like this little defensive guy
and he made me sort of plant my feet and
go i'm going to take punches i'm going
to get used to it and i'm going to
defend them i'm going to block them but
i'm also going to start
controlling that ring don't you move
from this spot do this
don't move for me put your toes opposite
mine
yes stay there
are you trying to hit me in the face
okay
it's very rare that um another man makes
me feel like that
when you care about another bloke and
you develop that
like friendship there's a bit of you
that i don't want to [__] hurt derek
you know what i mean but like
this is part of the learning experience
is understanding that this is what we're
here to do
like it isn't like we're actually trying
to rip each other's heads off but
it's a bit of an unusual thing to punch
someone you like
i've got to give credit to derek because
obviously there's everything needs
working on my boxing game right now but
he's good at
looking at what is a priority this
lesson really addressed some of the
major things i was doing wrong in
previous weeks
better guys that now you're getting it
now you yay now you're getting it
it's better than standing like a
flipping telegraph hold on remember what
you've been taught
remember just a minute though
so what's happening here is derek has
spent most of this session teaching me
how to fight in the pocket
and i've spent all of this time
memorizing okay this is what i do here
this is what i do there he's been right
okay
now we're gonna have a little spa and
you're gonna put that into practice
he's come out the first thing he does is
change to southpaw it's completely
[__] me over like
now i'm like having to reconsider
everything all over again
i'm mentally struggling right now like
he's got me flustered and
i wasn't expecting this so i'm sort of
giving up a little bit on myself because
i just can't seem to find the tools for
the job
why
because i was [__] there would rehearse
four rounds of you doing left hands
foreign i'm finally writing ears on you
you go right hand i'm like i switched on
purpose
i've got no answer for this exactly
[__] i'm in a huffy i'm not even gonna
lie i'm totally in a huff
i'm just so [__] off i just wasn't
able to use everything you just taught
us
because when it comes to practicing
because you're born left-handed yeah
yeah [__] that [__]
someone's going to beat me beat you beat
anyone my son
you think you're just going to roll that
bend and think oh i was born left-handed
lottery i was born left-handed
and i'm going to win no it's universal
what i taught you is universal it goes
for orthodox
and southpaw the fundamentals remain the
same
okay and looking back at it he was doing
everything for my own good day
and he taught me a very valuable lesson
but sometimes those lessons
at the time they they hurt your ego
[__] enough
okay
[__] sake oh nearly but derek is so
quick to react and i've left my chin
right out there and he
[__] plans one on us
he didn't know you know even that is
right on the jaw
boom the impact of the head shakes back
and then the jaw up
[__] vibrating jesus christ son when
derek's in there
to him it's like driving the car he's in
first gear he's putting the hammer oh
yeah
he just knows what he's doing you know i
mean with me i'm the learner driver so
i'm having to think of every little
thing that i need to do in there
and for him it just comes so natural
there's no thought needed and that's
what i want to get to
my goal isn't like a lot of these
youtube boxers for example god bless
them get your money lad but i'm not
looking for glory
i'm looking for skill i want to i want
to get education i want to
learn about fighting by being in there
you know what i mean so that when i am
talking about fighting
as much as everyone wants to call me the
fight casual and all that i want to pay
my dues i want to get these skills and i
want to feel like i've earned the right
to some degree at least to not just be
the couch expert but i say yeah i've
[__] been in there i know how it
[__] feels and
i've done it
you're taking it pretty well to be
honest i don't know how you are when you
go home
well i'm going to do the kickoff now
something
they must let me think what the [__] is
this gun playing that
[Music]
step up
i'm [__] dreading this i'm not gonna
lie what now this is light man
yeah well it's it's it's more how i'm
feeling they
mix with the idea of getting punished
this was the first time that we'd used
both hands full sparring although we're
not throwing hard punches here we're
just
getting me in the habit of using both
hands
nice
[Music]
it was weird because it had been so long
of me just jabbing
and going body shots without using the
right hand i kind of had to remember
that it was there
hey you've got to say about those
moments when you actually
do it in an actual combination i'm
slipping i'm landing obviously it's not
full power but before people slag us off
i know i'm not muhammad ali here and i
know this is just two guys far and
they're going soft we're not trying to
hit each other hard
but i i'm taking every little win i
can't at this point and you see
when he comes in here derek i'll read
the punch correctly
answer him he comes back in again
after i've gone for three i read it
perfectly
and again i hit him with another couple
that's a massive win for me because less
than a couple of months before this
i was getting belted all around the
footman ring with body shots and i had
no idea what the [__] i was doing
so the next session started like any
other we're hitting pads
derek's like yeah you're going to spot
me today for a round i'm like okay cool
he's like then you're gonna spoil
someone else are you sure like derek has
been my
comfort zone like he is my coach i know
although i might get smacked up a bit he
isn't gonna take the piss
and there's a level of responsibility
there for him to not [__] me up
whereas someone else that isn't there he
said yeah you're sparring a nissan kit
please welcome that was a big punch by
gibble the beast from ace
that's just non-stop pressure from
kibble relentless
body shots
no more i'm everywhere baby for those
who don't know any son gabe he has been
one of the original youtube boxers he
has been boxing for at least three years
if not longer
he was on every big boxing card
including his own against jake paul
he lost against jake paul but he went
after him he landed punches
and he is known to be ferocious his
biggest strength
is his fitness my biggest weakness is my
fitness and at the time of this
uh spa he was 100 kilograms
almost like the guy was a cruiserweight
you know what i mean so it wasn't that
big of a size difference that you'd
expect because
he is thick right now he has all the
experience that's the main thing is i
was thinking
he's been boxing three years i've been
boxing three months once or twice a week
you know this guy's been the mayweather
gym you know what i mean he's
i respect you you know yeah you lost one
fight you battled the other two [__] so
yeah i was aware that i would have a
height and reach advantage
but at the same time cable if i get
tired is going to be all over me and
that is a miserable
experience for everyone the ksi all of
them have said like
he pushes the pace on you and it's
[__] horrible but
derek told us to do it so that's what i
was going to do and obviously we weren't
going to try and rip each other's heads
off there was no right hands
you know to the head it was jabbing body
punches i knew
it was a really good test for me to find
out just where i was at at this point
so you both suit the heavies yeah or
your bridge away and you look at heavy
weights
what's the bridge away the weight in
nice and easy
remember both you can move both ways
[Music]
there you go good job bro man
you've got a double gap to get excited
[Music]
that's it there you go now you relax
one more round with the trap
[Music]
all right move your back with your left
that's it
good don't go back in the straight line
[Music]
okay
defense
i think the main thing was he just never
goes away does he
no i faced the ceiling at one point you
grabbed the top of my head and i went
like that
i could see i can see the scene he's
improved a lot he's improved a lot and i
know he would improve
i knew he would improve with my deadline
what i expected to see
i've seen and that's improvement well
derek was happy with how i did so i was
happy
but obviously i was thinking i could
have done this i could have done that
there's
a few mistakes i'll be obviously i'm
going to make mistakes all the time and
i'm sure
gabe was thinking i could have done this
i could have done that because the first
time you spar someone new it's a bit
whoa this is different especially
because me and gibb are so different
in what our abilities are gimbal's the
stamina pressure guy and i'm
a big tall [__] gorilla there's a
weird sort of bond that you
get from a situation like that because
you sort of give your body over the
other guy and well you can beat me up
and learn from it
and i can beat you up and i'll learn
from it we're helping each other
and i have respect for anyone who gets
in the ring
especially gimbal because obviously i
was so much bigger than him he is a
fighter right in there this guy so
respect the gimbal for a start and i was
proud that i
i was composed it wasn't about uh
winning and losing it was about doing
what i'd been taught
when i had someone completely different
and something completely new coming at
me and can i remember it
in that event and i did i'm still just
learning i'm i'm a baby like i say a few
months in this now
but i'm loving it boxing's been one of
the best things
to happen to my mental health and i
still have [__] major law days i'm
not even gonna deny it there's some days
i think what the [__]
am i doing here on this planet what's
the point we all have those
but it really it makes me happy digging
deep inside yourself to find out what
you're made of
it's good for you challenging yourself
is good for you it's as hard as it is it
makes you value yourself more it gives
you self-worth
so i [__] recommend it you know
looking back at the first rebuild i
think i just tried to bite off more than
i could
i was doing weight lifting i was talking
about trying to fix my mental health i
was trying to
learn how to box and i realized like
some things just need more focus than
others you can't spin all those plates
at once while having
a job and and friends and family and all
of that so
weightlifting for example that slowly
calmed down because i realized
you cannot weightlift like a powerlifter
and then trying to be epoxy your muscles
just aren't going to [__] hack it
and my mental health definitely still
needs more time
and attention so jim shark
have talked to me about you know this
gymshark 66 thing that they do which is
a campaign to help getting people
inspired at the start
of the new year i'll put the link in the
description below i mentioned it at the
start
and i'd encourage you all give yourself
a challenge for me personally
um i want to get fitter because that's
the main thing holding me back
i'm learning the boxing but i'm getting
too tired i'm gassing out i'm
you know even at the end against cable
i'm i'm getting tired and he's just
fresh
you know what i mean so that's my main
goal for this year is to
try and run more try and do more cardio
get this [__] weight off me i'm still
stuck on 21 stone which is where i was
on the last rebuild and that's the main
thing is
my diet all of that it hasn't been there
but
like i say i think i just bit off more
than i could choose so this is my
give myself one clear goal is to just
get fitter hopefully lose some weight i
will if you all want it in the comments
i'll read them
keep you updated and do another rebuild
episode if he's won it
i really hope he's enjoyed this one it's
been a lot of blood sweat and tears as
you
have seen thanks to me true fans the
ones who really look out for us the ones
who have me back
use me in the world to us and i probably
don't say it enough because i think i
just close off from the world sometimes
because
of my mental health i just don't want to
go through the [__]
of the trolls and all the negativity
that's online but
you know i say your comments i know
you're there i know you've got me back
and i really appreciate it so big love
take care of yourselves
and each other and i'll see you later
[Laughter]
[Music]
you